Let's go next to Lamar from London. Lamar
from London. You're on. What's going on?
Hey, thanks for picking up. My pleasure. So
I've seen a video with just CENI Peterson. Yeah,
great job on that. It's really entertaining. I was
wondering, you seem to be on the same page with
conservatives, like kind of sounds and kind
of playing identity politics, and they like to
kind of make out as if that's something
that people on the left like to do.
I'm really curious as to like whether you would
interview kind of Candace Owens or other like
conservatives like Larry Elder and so
forth and kind of confront them or not,
because that listen, I'm Candice Solons.
We've had there's been so much back and
forth with Candice Owens. I was as far as I
knew, I was supposed to be on a panel with her
at Politico a couple years ago. And then she said
she was never even asked and was never even going
to Politico on. At this point, I don't know that
she would be willing to talk to me, but I would
gladly host her on my program or appear on hers.
Larry Elder. OK, maybe I don't know that Larry
Elder is the most relevant to my audience,
but I have no opposition in principle to it.
Yeah, definitely, I just think that would
be really interesting because I think and
even Charlie cut, for instance, this thing.
They change their arguments quite frequently
and they're not very consistent. No, but that, you
know, that fan bases think that they're the most
intelligent people in the world. Yes. I would
just it would be really interesting to hear.
So I was actually thinking the other day
I saw a totally delusional clip of Charlie
Kirk yelling about how, you know, basically your
life depends on voting Trump. It was it was crazy.
But I was wondering, like, what happens
to Charlie Kirk if Trump loses, you know?
Yeah, exactly. I mean, he was he
was found out the other day off for,
like, having this fake green starting point or
something like that. I think I read about it and
they were kind of swaying people
not to vote or something like that.
They were astroturfing somewhere. Yeah. Who
can even keep up it? It's hard to even know.
Hey, Lamar, real quick question. How can. Can
you clarify for me in in British English as youth
speak proper British English. What is the how do
you pronounce that the virus. We call it. It's
spelled CLV I.D.. How do you pronounce that of it?
Oh, you do. Oh, wow. Okay. My God. All right.
People are right. All right. Well, Lamar, on that
note, I appreciate the phone call. I've been duly,
duly humbled. And I appreciate
you pronouncing that for me.
Thanks. Great talking to you. All right. There is
Lamar from London. Very, very exciting. Let I see.
McKenzie is very aggressively saying that
they were not given a full opportunity. Yo